this is as close as they will get police
have sealed off the area leading to
Schloss mo these n ty g7 cyclists will
stop kilometers away from their intended
target after lengthy discussions with
authorities that were finally allowed to
bring their bicycles to the protest this
is a bow chika this is harassment you
can clearly see there's plenty of room
here for these 50 bikes the situation is
rather tense it was a laid-back morning
for President Obama though Chancellor
Merkel treated him to a traditional
Bavarian breakfast in the nearby village
of kun accusations of us buying have
rankled german-american relations still
Marco says the Alliance is sound what's
my job my not despite some differences
of opinion the United States remains our
friend and partner an essential partner
with whom we continue to work closely
with me that's being properly an Obama
outlined his goals for the summit and
had some choice words for Russia that
sanctions will remain in place until the
Ukraine crisis is resolved over the next
two days in Schloss elmo we're going to
discuss our shared future a global
economy that creates jobs and
opportunity standing up to Russian
aggression in Ukraine combating threats
from violent extremism to climate change
but the Ukraine crisis is expected to
top the agenda over the next two days
the seven world leaders are ensconced in
this luxury resort in the Bavarian Alps
so far they have been undisturbed by the
small number of anti g7 protesters who
have tried to reach the hotel they are
determined to make an impact no matter
how small but they are far outnumbered
by security forces security is also high
in nearby garmisch-partenkirchen where
left-wing radicals marched against
Sunday but so far there's been no repeat
of the violent clashes on Saturday
you